♪ ♪
>> I'M HELENA, I'M 23 YEARS OLD.
WHEN I WAS ABOUT 15 I STARTED
USING TUMBLER.
I HAD AN EATING DISORDER SINCE I
WAS PRETTY YOUNG.
THERE WAS A LOT OF MESSAGES THAT
SAID, IF YOU FEEL BAD ABOUT YOUR
BODY, THAT MEANS YOU ARE TRANS.
I WAS JUST GOING THROUGH THIS
PERIOD OF, LIKE, I DON'T LIKE
HOW I'M TREATED AS A
SALESPERSON.
I DON'T WANT TO BE SAYS, BECAUSE
THIS MEANS YOU ARE ON COOL.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE THAT.
AND I WAS REALLY INCENTIVIZED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE MY
VOICE HEARD.
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T CHANGE MY
RACE, I CAN'T REALLY CHANGE MY
SEXUALITY.
SO THE ONLY THING LEFT WAS TO
START PLAYING AROUND WITH THE
GENDER STUFF.
I DECIDED TO CALL MYSELF A
DEMIGIRL, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
40 MILLION GENDERS.
AND THAT BASICALLY MEANS THAT I
AM MOSTLY A GIRL, BUT I'M A
LITTLE BIT NOT A GIRL.
WHICH IS LIKE WHAT IS THAT EVEN
MEAN?
AFTER THAT I WENT TO DEMIBOY,
AND AFTER THAT I WANT TO GENDER
FLUID.
AFTER THAT I EVENTUALLY WENT TO
TRANS BOY.
BUT ALL OF THIS TOOK TWO OR
THREE YEARS OF JUST GOING
THROUGH THIS REPETITIVE CYCLE OF
CHANGING THIS IDENTITY AND
CHANGING IT AGAIN AND IT WAS
JUST NEVER ENOUGH.
THERE WAS A LOT OF HOPELESSNESS
FOR A LONG TIME.
A LOT OF REGRET.
THE FEELING OF REGRET WAS
INTENSE.
>> Tucker: IT IS A MOVING
INTERVIEW PREP IS A LOT MORE OF
IT IN THE EPISODE.
HELENA JOINS US ON SITE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THERE'S SOMETHING SO SAD ABOUT
IT.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING UP, YOUR
VOICE MATTERS.
BUT YOU FELT WHAT EVERY YOUNG
WOMAN I'VE EVER MET FELT AT A
CERTAIN AGE WHICH IS
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH YOURSELF.
IT FELT LIKE YOU ARE EXPLOITED.
>> IT'S COMPLETELY NORMAL FOR
YOUNG GIRLS AND BOYS TO FEELING
COMFORTABLE WITH THEMSELVES AND
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH HER BODY, BUT
WE HAVE THIS IDEOLOGY THAT IS
ESPECIALLY PREVALENT ONLINE THAT
SAYS IF YOU HAVE THOSE FEELINGS,
THAT MEANS YOU ARE TRANS.
THERE ARE LITERALLY PEOPLE THAT
SAY, IF YOU DON'T EVEN LIKE YOUR
VOICE ON THE RECORDING, THAT IS
ASSIGNED OF GENDER DYSPHORIA AND
DO NEED TO GO SEE A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL BECAUSE YOU ARE
TRAMS.
>> Tucker: TALK ABOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE.
HOW DO YOU -- AND THIS IS ALL
EXPLAINED IN GREATER DEPTH IN
THE DOCUMENTARY, BUT HOW DO YOU
FEEL NOW AT 23 LOOKING BACK AT
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I FEEL GRATEFUL FOR THE
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE IT TAUGHT ME
A LOT ABOUT THE WORLD AND ABOUT
MYSELF, BUT THEY REALLY FEEL
AFRAID FOR THESE OTHER YOUNG
GIRLS LIKE MYSELF.
I CONSIDER MYSELF LUCKY THAT I
WAS ABLE TO GET OUT OF IT
UNSCARRED, REALLY MEDICALLY, BUT
THERE'S SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T SAY THE SAME.
AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY AS WELL.
IT IS JUST DEVASTATING,
ESPECIALLY FROM A YOUNG AGE, BE
LIED TO BY ADULTS AT SCHOOL AND
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND TOLD
THAT YOUR BODY IS WRONG.
THAT IS DEVASTATING FOR A YOUNG
PERSON.
FOR YOUNGER GIRLS AND BOYS THAT
I ONCE WAS, BEING LED BY THIS
PATH HAD BEEN HURT BY IT.
>> Tucker: IT DOES FEEL LIKE
SOME OF THE STEPS ARE MEDICALLY
IRREVERSIBLE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE IS ALL SORTS OF -- THE
WHITE HOUSE JUST PUT OUT A CHART
YESTERDAY THAT SAYS THAT SOME OF
THESE STEPS ARE REVERSIBLE OR
PARTIALLY REVERSIBLE.
WHEN YOU GO ON A HORMONE -- THAT
IS GOING TO GIVE YOU NOT JUST
PHYSICAL CHANGES, BUT
PSYCHOLOGICAL EXPERIENCES THAT
YOU CAN'T JUST ACT LIKE THEY
NEVER HAPPENED.
YOU CAN'T JUST TAKE IT BACK.
ESPECIALLY WITH SURGERIES.
A BREAST IMPLANT AFTER A
VASECTOMY IS NOT THE SAME THING
OF NEVER TAKING THEM OFF IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
A DOUBLE MASTECTOMY AT 16, 17,
18 YEARS OLD OR EVEN YOUNGER.
THERE IS NOTHING YOU SHOULD DO
TO PUT THAT FEELING OF ONENESS
AND SAFETY IN YOUR BODY BACK.
>> Tucker: IT IS
HEARTBREAKING.
I HOPE PEOPLE ARE HEARING YOU
WITH OPEN MINDS, WITH TOLERANCE,
ARE THEY?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE, ESPECIALLY PARENTS, WHO
ARE REALLY THANKFUL FOR WHAT I'M
SAYING.
BECAUSE THEY SEE THEIR YOUNG
GIRL OR BOY GOING THROUGH THIS
AND ALL THEIR DOCTORS AND
TEACHERS ARE TELLING THEM -- AND
THE PARENTS KNOW THAT THEIR
CHILD SHOULD NOT BE HAVING THESE
COSMETIC PROCEDURES.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PARENTS WHO
ARE REALLY THANKFUL.
THERE ARE OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT I REALLY THANKFUL THAT OUR
SAME WHAT I'M SAYING, BUT
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE THE TRANS
ACTIVISTS AND THE TRIM COMMUNITY
THAT EXHIBITS SOME VERY
UNHEALTHY DYNAMICS THAT ARE
REALLY UPSET.
>> Tucker: IT YOU ARE SO
ARTICULATE AND THOUGHTFUL AT 23.
IT IS REMARKABLE.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUFFERED LIKE
YOU SOMETIMES GET DEEPER.
>> YOU LEARN A LOT.
LIKE I SAID.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU,
THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO US.
I APPRECIATE IT.
YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR HER FULL
STORY AND OTHERS OF PEOPLE LIKE
HER WHO HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
ON FOX NATION IN EARLY MAY.
IT IS ONE OF A BUNCH OF EPISODES
WE'VE BEEN WORKI